こんにちは！
はじめしゃちょーです
あ、ヤバい
超見られてる
ちょっと待ってちょっと待って...
今の現代
多くの人はスマートフォンを使っている
君も使ってないか？
世の中には溢れる
多くのネットワークが
我々社会人を
縛り付けている！
私は思ってしまった
今この...
ちょっと待って...
私は思ってしまった
この
この電話ボックス達は
今の現代使われているのか
可哀想に
誰にも使われず
静かに佇んでいる
電話ボックス達！
このご時世に
電話ボックスを使う人はいるのか
なので私は今から
俺が電話ボックスの中にいる間に
他の人がもう片方を使うのを待ちます
電話ボックスに人が来るまで
僕はこの中に入っています
つまり
二台あるから
俺が入ってても使えなくなるってことはないから
スマートフォンが普及しまくる世の中で
電話ボックスは果たして
使われているのかどうかっていうのをちょっと
見ていきたいと思います
では...
２４時間頑張りましょう
誰かが来るまで僕は絶対出ませんから
行ってきます
はい。というわけで始まりました
誰かが入ってくるまで電話ボックスから出れまテン
めちゃくちゃ暑いです
そして人目が気になります
あーもう多分ね
俺...予想なんだけど
マジでねー電話ボックス使う人いないと思うんだよね
なるべく頑張ってみます
もしもし？
そちらの状況は
［コチラの状況は］
［もうすぐ十分経ちますね］
もうすぐ十分？
あ！ヤバい切れそう！ヤバい！
切れたか...
ハイ２０分経ちました
一向に誰も使う気配がありません
だって皆スマートフォン持ってる訳じゃんね？
マジで誰も使わなかったら
俺多分一生出れないよココから
３０分越えました～
あ、もしもし。じーちゃん？
あ、はじめでーす
ちょっとね。暇だから電話してみました
え？今ね
公衆電話から電話かけてんだけど
うん。じゃあ、あれ
お盆にまた帰れたら帰るちゃー
うん。はーい
ばーちゃんも元気で
じゃあ。元気でね
うん。はーい
ばいばーい
［一時間経過しました］
［けど誰も来ません］
一時間経過しました
もうちょいつけといていい？
暇だから
あ。ヤベ。課金しまーす
いやぁーキツイなぁ
もしもし？
誰も公衆電話を使わないんだけど
今の世の中
いや暇じゃないから
そう。でもさー
使わないとさー
ダメじゃんね
入ってる限りは
［はい］
［２時間経ったんですけど］
［全然誰も使う気配ないです］
太陽が出てきました
電話ボックスの中の温度がヤバいです
めちゃくちゃ暑い
なんか頭痛とかも
なんだろ
熱中症みたいな症状に襲われております
それかもう最悪
[うん]
ネタ動画にするか
[それ...だよね多分]
「いつも見てます」
あぁ！ありがとうございます！
ありがとうございます！
お疲れ様です